i love this you are a pastor in el paso
we have like a third of a country
western song i love it yes yeah do they
call you al
pastor yeah you're el pastor from el
paso
uh tell me what about your the
denomination of your church uh
what what are your what is the religious
leaning of your flock well it's it's a
non-denominational church
oh nones are not completely
non-denominational yeah so
yeah okay so no i don't have to wear
vestments i've only had to wear
investments once
we can wear casual jeans we're like the
refreshed conan show where we can wear
casual jackets
and jeans yes thank you you know what
thank you my uh concept when we did a
revamp on our show was that i wanted the
show to be non-denominational
so that's why i just started dressing
like a casual el paso hipster pastor
and uh you and i are exactly on the same
track yeah
we essentially have just been watering
down whatever you do for the last 20 or
so years
put a fresh religious code of pain on it
now so this is fascinating to me
um i i i'm very excited to talk to you
because i have a lot of questions
first of all how large is your
non-denominational
congregation it's like three four
hundred people and do you
how many services a week do you do we do
two every sunday
so you can completely i mean i'm gonna
tell you something i was raised catholic
so of course they have to adhere to all
of this
strict text that i know by heart because
i went to thousands and thousands of
catholic masses
uh and i know it all by heart you get to
freestyle
it's is that right well sort of
i will say this we've done something
partially inspired by your show that i
think we're regretting now
so wait a minute you're a religious
leader and you're
you're doing something that you got from
our show you're a
terrible pastor terrible let me but
but i might need your help with this so
here's here's what we did so one of the
things i loved is
seeing how you came back and essentially
just
trying to entertain people just did
whatever you could think of
for several weeks stuck at home i
remember you carrying around
life-size cutouts of kevin hart in your
backyard i remember
you know all this stuff and and after
watching a couple weeks of it i realized
we can literally do anything right now
so and
like in this pandemic era we can do it
we can try anything
so we tried uh doing a sock puppet
in lieu of not being able to actually
teach kids and have like classes for
kids on sundays
we tried doing this sock puppet and now
we can't stop
now the sock puppet has to appear every
week for people get angry and
when you say people get it first of all
don't blame me for your sock puppet bit
okay you know that's not don't put that
on me
man uh you made the choice
to sit don't say oh i watched cohn and
he was freestyling a bit so then we did
a sock puppet
the sock puppet is obviously for kids
and
is it the kids who insist that it comes
back because when the adults are saying
hey man where's the sock puppet you have
a problem
that is exactly what's happening really
the adults were like
where's the puppet because before we do
like
the sermon or homily or or whatever you
want to call it we we
we do a mini version for the kids
because we haven't been able to do cat
classes you know because of safety
reasons and stuff and so
we basically have to do a mr rogers
version of the sermon in two minutes
four children with a sock puppet but i
now i
we can't get rid of him so we need a way
you can't get rid of him meaning he's
too popular yeah he's too impossible
that you do it
like oh and and and so i'm wondering if
you've ever had a bit
that you feel like you know what this
bit needs to we need to write this we
need to be done with a bit but you can't
because people just keep
what do i do first of all the first i
still have more questions first of all
i totally relate to we have a bit and
it's got to stop
that i've experienced uh since 1993
about 650
000 times that happens all the time um
how do you stop it uh that's a very good
question
uh yes because we had a this is going
way way way back uh to the beginning of
the show but we had a character
called pimpbot he's a robot pimp
and um so very similar very similar
and he yeah by the way i just forgot
that you were a pastor uh but anyway
he was a robot pimp and so he was a he
was like a bad
1950s robot bleep bleep blur blurp but
he he was dressed like a
you know late 60s 70s stereotypical pimp
and he was always talking about
his profession in very graphic way and
people love pimpbot and then we stopped
doing it in like 94
for 10 years after that whenever i would
pass young people they'd be like dude
pimpbot pimpa when's he coming back and
i thought it's been a decade
and you're still asking me about pimpa
and they'd be like jim pimpa we've gotta
have pimpot
so i'm gonna tell you right now that
it's very hard
to get rid of especially once you've
created a character
and a puppet no less what's the name of
the puppet
freddy the moose oh oh you're screwed
freddie the moose i haven't even seen
freddy the moose and i love freddie the
moose
that's cute you can't get rid of freddie
the moose no
i forbid you oh no this is backfiring
this is not
i have our i'm not going to help you get
rid of freddie the moose freddie the
moose i wish i had thought afraid of the
moose in fact
tune in next week you may see me talking
to my own freddie the moose i'll change
it
just a little bit so i can steal it but
when you see me talking to teddy the elk
you'll know that you've been ripped off
[Laughter]
but wait a minute how does he talk how
does he sound can you give us a little
of him
okay do you want to see him um well
that's
uh okay yeah you don't have to it's okay
no no no no no that's of course we want
to see you know we want to see him but
but back me up team
doesn't this sound a little bit like one
of those ventriloquists who's
talking about his dummy a little too
much it's not and then he says
and then he says then he says do you
want to meet him
and then he says oh he's got quite the
life
and then you all start to get scared and
we back out of the room yeah yeah yeah
you're screaming and then later sona's
sleeping and little tiny hands start to
strangle her
he's gonna come in just just briefly
he's gonna say hi and then he's going to
peace out he's very busy
whoa this is a separate entity oh my god
look at him
he's adorable let's hear him let's see
who am i what you don't recognize me
i've been on television for 30 years
what do you mean who are you how dare
you hello mr gohan
it's conan not cohan i'm not george m
cohan
oh my god the person working the puppet
has no idea who i
am this is so insulting on so many
levels hello who are you
hello mr cohan goodbye freddie
[Music]
no no you know what i love freddie what
everybody could name sona and me
perfectly
yeah yeah yeah i really prefer matt
gourley he's a terrific podcaster
and sonam obsession i mean her trip to
armenia was inspiring
now who's cohan
so specific i love it that puppet took
me down that puppet's a lot like triumph
the insult comic dog he took me right
out at the knees
and i feel uh i feel bested um
why get rid of him what's wrong what's i
don't see a problem here you have a bit
in in my profession if you have a bit
that's working and making people
happy you've struck gold keep
the puppet going what's wrong with it
well i i think we're gonna have to now
at this point because you've you've
validated him and he's gonna now
want to hire billing on the liturgy
i mean above god he's going to want to
be above yeah i mean
we got all kinds of headaches now let me
ask you something let's say someone god
forbid
passed away and there was a funeral
right
the puppet freddy wouldn't show up and
be like oh
i'm so sad mr
smith it's not smith it's samuels
whatever passed away you're not gonna
he wouldn't show up at that would he
look at this point
what oh my god what freddie candy i feel
like he's driving the bus
and i feel like at this point my
performance review is gonna be with him
at the end of the year yeah yeah yeah
that's right well
uh this has all the makings of a
terrific horror movie
a pastor his puppet in el paso look at
all the peas and the plosives
yeah a pastor and his puppet in el paso
are trapped
uh in this hellish duel to the death the
two of you
because you can't get rid of him and his
power grows every day and yours weakens
yeah it's true now at some point the way
this movie might end
is the puppet becomes more like you
you become more like the puppet and at
the end freddie's giving
the liturgy this sermon whatever you
call it the
what do you call it the discernment the
talk the sermon
and then you're brought in you're the
puppet
oh and oh man and you become
that which you loathed and now he's in
charge
i think we could sell this i think this
is yeah a saleable
concept well first of all that means a
lot coming from a pastor in el paso
because who knows this business better
than you listen conan ricky
i have no million-dollar ideas here